heute geht es im kaffeesatz der landet
nämlich viel zu oft in der tonne obwohl
man den im garten eigentlich super
sinnvoll verwenden kann
du kannst ihn zb auf seinen beeten
ausbringen das wild gegen schnecken
ameisen und katzen und wenn du richtig
viel kaffee trinkt dann kannst du im
kaffeesatz auch deine eigenen außenseite
dinge ziehen die wachsen werden nämlich
auch richtig gut und kaffeesatz ist auch
ein toller dünger vor allem für die
pflanzen die es ein bisschen sauer mögen
wie zb die hi dp ang
und wenn du das alles erledigt hast und
immer noch kaffeesatz übrig ist dann
solltest du definitiv weniger kaffee
trinken